the tell-all book that caused a dramatic
breakup between President Trump and his
former chief strategist is on sale this
morning that is four days earlier than
planned fire and fury shows Steve Bannon
and other White House officials
questioning the president's ability to
do his job publication was moved up
after a lawyer for mr. Trump sent a
threatening letter to the publisher the
president tweeted last night that the
book is quote full of lies
misrepresentations and sources that
don't exist
look at this guy's past and watch what
happens to him and sloppy Steve
referring to Steve Bannon chip Reid is
at the white house watching the
spreading fallout chip good morning well
good morning and here it is and in this
book Michael Wolfe writes that Steve
Bannon said there was a 33% chance that
the Muller investigation would lead to
the impeachment of President Trump and a
33% chance that Trump would resign he's
not going to make it he said he's lost
his stuff thank you very much for being
here
reporters asked President Trump Thursday
whether he felt betrayed by his former
strategist Steven Bannon Bannon had
spoken fondly of the president the night
before but the firestorm around the book
raged on it's completely tabloid gossip
full of false and fraudulent claims the
president's lawyer Charles harder
demanded that the books publisher Henry
Holt cease and desist from any further
publication or face a possible lawsuit
the publisher brushed off the threat and
moved the on sale date from next Tuesday
to today citing unprecedented demand the
book details dysfunction among the White
House staff and also raises questions
about the president's mental state
author Michael Wolfe writes the staff
became concerned that Trump's rambling
and his alarming repetitions had
significantly increased and that his
ability to stay focused never great had
notably declined in an article for The
Hollywood Reporter Wolfe continues he
was in words used by almost every member
of the senior staff on repeated
occasions like a child wolf writes they
all 100% came to believe he was
incapable of functioning in his job it's
disgraceful and laughable White House
press secretary
Terry Sara Huckabee Sanders forcefully
denied those claims if he was unfit he
probably wouldn't be sitting there and
wouldn't have defeated the most
qualified group of candidates the
Republican Party has ever seen as for
why he continued to talk to Steven
Bannon four months after firing him mr.
Trump dismissed it the fallout from the
book has not done much good for Bannon
either CBS News has confirmed that White
House officials urged bannon's longtime
benefactor
Rebecca Mercer to cut all ties with him
in the aftermath of fire and fury Jeff
chip thank you very much